what is the most impact of individual
psychology we have it's usually leaders
of countries or leaders of major
organizations and so on and one of the
things you mentioned with benign
narcissism it's that seems to be aligned
with success right if you care about
your own success
that that's going to be you're more
likely to be have narcissistic
Tendencies I suppose
um and so my question is when you
follow that threat of narcissism to
become the leader of a country
now you have a lot of new interesting
psychological complexities to deal with
like power that old cliche that power
corrupts
does that
is it possible for power to corrupt the
human mind to where it pushes you
farther and farther
into a malignant narcissism into this
destructive Envy what are your thoughts
on power like the effect of power in the
human mind yeah
power is
um
it's an accentuator right an intensifier
right so so I think it is true that
there are people who can be sort of in a
gray area where there are malignant
narcissistic Tendencies and and
behaviors but there are also ways in
which that person can think outside of
themselves and think in a broader way
and and think sort of kindly about
others and and they're they're sort of
trying to navigate whether they're aware
or not that they're trying to navigate
between one and the other and then the
Allure of power is well just look just
exercise that power and you'll feel
better right it'll show you right that
you're good enough look at the power you
have and whatever may be going on in the
person's mind that then power yes can
corrupt yes I think that's why we we
have to have checks and balances right
because we don't you know we we're all
inscrutable to ourselves let alone to
others so so we must have checks and
balances and we should always have them
on ourselves as well as on others we
should we should want that for the
health of ourselves in the world around
us
um so I think all of that is true but
there are also people who don't
necessarily become corrupted by power
right that there can be an understanding
and a grounding uh that they're a
steward of power right uh you know a
Shepherd you know I mean the ways people
describe utilizing power and utilizing
it a benign what it in a benign way that
then Fosters the healthy aspects of self
right so like gratitude and humility
right if I mean if we if we could add a
healthy dose of gratitude and humility
to everyone or to our society there
would be a sea change right but how do
you how do you feel gratitude how do you
feel humility those things are
incompatible with narcissism Envy right
with really the bad pull of things that
we're talking about and part of the
reason I you know I'm so focused in my
work and really what runs through all of
my thoughts about life is that the
impact of trauma right because trauma
you know creates these false lessons and
it walls us off from truth and and you
know it starts to point towards the the
unhealthy ways of
um of trying to feel better about
ourselves but we have the health in US
too we have those Seeds of Health too
that can grow into being a steward of
power and sharing power being
considerate and kind and we see a lot of
that in the world too right it's not all
just the evil we you know we see plenty
of people who do good and who are
generous of spirit and you know we have
both in us and it is I think you're
talking about our culture and what the
seeds that we sow and and the climate
that we set including putting Governors
and boundaries around like how do we how
do we rein in or say that the more
aggressive the more envious or
destructive is unacceptable right how do
we Foster the the part that's kind and
considerate and reflective and and slow
to judge of like hey let's learn a
little bit more like how do we Foster
that and I think a lot of that comes
back to early childhood education I mean
I think we don't do nearly enough to
protect children and and as a corollary
to that we don't do nearly enough to
educate children and we said I want to
write a book second book I write is
gonna it's gonna be everything I needed
to know about life I learned as a second
year postgraduate Psychiatry residents I
was like why you know why then did I
learn so much about unconscious
motivation about the impact of trauma
about how we can be envious and how we
can act out you know even about how our
emotions Trump logic in us like what why
why don't we teach these things when
we're young enough to understand like
why is that other kid bullying me right
or why just because I'm a little bit
bigger do I want to go thump that other
kid on the head like what what what's
going on that we don't we don't do those
things you know we just we're tripping
ahead of ourselves and we don't stop and
think
how are we using our resources how are
we how are we shepherding forward the
Next Generation which by the way is a
generation that's going to determine our
Fates too right as we get older but we
don't you know do that I often think of
like in the Olympics you know you see
like the the great sprinters right and
they've got to come out of the blocks
perfectly right because if they come out
of the blocks a little bit too fast
they're going to fall over right they're
going to just fall forward and and I I
often see that in my head about us as
you know as humans and as a culture that
we're we're rushing so far forward we
don't stop and say wait let's let's keep
the basics here the basic techniques of
like how are we navigating forward in in
Life or do we just throw all those away
because I can get some benefit by
saying that you're bad even though
what's being leveled against you is
wrong right like what why why do do I
take that or do I say no there's
something more important here that we
want to Shepherd forward in ourselves as
a culture and I think preventing
childhood trauma and changing the ways
that we educate children and adults
would could again make a sea change and
maybe set us on a course towards even
towards a greater likelihood of survival
as a species yeah so talking to like uh
people in elementary school
about human nature
and teaching them was so uh how people
can be resentful and envious and how how
to deal with your emotions uh how to uh
yeah so these basic interaction things
about human relationships about
friendships about betrayal about love
about all those things like it just it's
actually strange that we don't we kind
of hope the parents talk about that kind
of stuff right but then the parents
often
uh you know need therapy themselves the
parents who couldn't learn it right I
mean I'm not joking that I was I was mad
you know second year after medical
school like how is it like I think even
things in my own life and you know how I
you know like how much shame I felt
after my brother's suicide like I was
already an adult right as a young adult
but I felt so much shame I didn't like I
had no understanding that that oh look
it's it's a it's a reflex to trauma
right to feel guilt and shame and that
of course I was feeling that it didn't
mean it was true because I felt it but I
mapped the fact that I felt ashamed to
the fact that I should have felt guilty
and ashamed and I like led to some very
negative things in my life and I had to
sort of pull myself back from and
recover from and like I didn't know that
right I didn't know the automaticity of
the reflex and how pervasive it can be
and how it can put blinders on us and I
mean it's just one example but you know
it's example of something big that
happens to people that we don't learn
learn about and I find myself sometimes
having conversations with a person
because you know I still do a lot of
clinical care of having conversations
with a person after a tragedy and I'm
saying I can't believe right again I'm
saying the things that this person
didn't learn in elementary school
because like none of us did right and
then look at the misery and the
suffering and then I think this is one
person among how many millions Among Us
who you know who try and go about their
way without knowing things that are
easily knowable because they don't even
know that they're knowable because we
don't teach them to ourselves